this is the psych Ultra ebike from our
sponsor syy crown and I've got to say
this is probably my favorite ebike of
2023 because it has one very important
feature to me that not a lot of ebikes
actually have these days and I'll
explain what I mean in just a minute but
as you guys can see we're out here in
the rain we have our VY rain coats but
this thing is fun because it actually
has IP X4 water resistance so it's
completely fine and we've been out here
having a
[Music]
[Applause]
blast but before I get into my favorite
feature I do want to give you guys a
general rundown of the the specs the
features and the design now this thing
first of all has a really nice paint
finish you have this two-tone with these
nice color options as you can see this
thing is really big it has 26 by4 in fat
tires absolutely massive supports a
payload or a load of
330 lbs so big guys like me and bigger
this is great for you now what I really
love is that this thing goes up to 28
mph which means that it's a class 3E
bike it has a buffing 750 W Motor that
actually Peaks out at 1,000 WTS so it
has a ton of torque and the really nice
thing is that you can either choose the
pedal assist or pass or you can use the
throttle which is right here on your
left handlebar it's also got the shimono
9-speed derailer with these paddle
shifters at the front and right under
here is the 48v 15 amp hour LG lithium
battery pack that will go over 50 Mi or
30 Mi just purely using the throttle
alone and as far as charging you could
actually easily remove the battery pack
with the included keys and charge it
kind of like in your office or at home
or it actually has a rubber grommet
right over here that seals it away from
the weather and you just plug it in
through there and the nice little
surprise especially at this price point
is that you get hydraulic disc brakes on
both the front and the back and on top
of that you get dual air suspension the
front and for the rear right right here
and of course you have your preload
settings and everything right over here
so really really nice suspension that's
super smooth and one of my personal
favorit is of course this huge huge very
comfortable seat that actually has
shocks built in I think this is the most
comfortable seat that I have used out of
any ebike so far very nice and one thing
that's quite unique about this is that
it has a really nice custom LCD smart
display that first of all looks really
cool gives you all of your options it's
very easy to use these buttons and
settings you got dedicated buttons for
the light at the front which by the way
is extremely bright probably the
brightest one that I've seen in any
ebike four separate LEDs very nice of
course you have the horn and you also
get a free oneyear warranty and now
let's get into my favorite feature that
personally made this my favorite ebike
of this year and that is the fact that
you can use this throttle right here on
your left handle to literally Go full
speed 28
mph which is incredibly important to me
because I use other ebikes that were
twice as expensive as this one but the
throttle is actually limited to 20 M
hour so I had this issue where I was
going 28 and then I would accidentally
twist the throttle with my hand
unintentionally and it would instantly
cut the power down to 20 M hour which is
extremely extremely annoying and I've
been looking at this design up close and
I'm super impressed by the build quality
for example you have this super clean
layout where the cables go perfectly
into the frame so subtle and stealth it
just looks amazing plus you also have
this bar that protects your shimono
derailer just really good attention to
detail on this bike and a really nice
bonus is that they included a phone
bounds and the box so check out how easy
it is to use you just press down there
you go your phone's not going anywhere
when you're done click the button super
super nice detail they added in and I
also love this little detail they made
for the brakes where you have this
little bolt that you can adjust to
basically make it easier and more
responsive to hit the brakes so with all
that said the general build quality is
absolutely amazing I love the two-tone
paint the design everything about it is
really really premium and the best part
is that right now it's currently on sale
for
$1,400 and it actually has a coupon for
$100 extra off so $1,300 for this class
3 ebike fully loaded jam-packed with all
of these amazing features it's basically
in incredible value because we actually
reviewed another ebike that thing was
$2800 overall I actually like this bike
better than that one and it's half the
price right now if you use the link in
the video description below so overall
guys this has got to be my favorite
ebike of
2023 hopefully you enjoyed this review
if you did subscribe above definitely
check that link below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video